hi i'm alana and i am currently in
mandatory quarantine
in a hotel in australia in a room that i
am not allowed to leave for the next
14 or so days for anyone who doesn't
know me who might be watching this video
because i do hope this will be helpful
for any australians who might want to
try to come home i am an australian
citizen so i didn't need any of the
exemptions uh to anyone trying to get
into australia who's not a citizen
i definitely cannot help you with that
it seems very complicated
aussies were allowed to just fly
straight home basically i didn't have to
do anything special
to actually be allowed to book the
flight but yes for the strangers among
us um i've not been home since
2019 and i'm very close to my family so
that's been
very hard i would try to come home or at
least see a family member every 12
months but naturally due to this
thing called a global pandemic i wasn't
able to now australia in terms of travel
across the board has been
extremely strict that is why i am in the
situation that i am in that to a lot of
you will sound pretty wild
but also meant that you know while i was
living in la which is where i work
i wasn't so worried about my australian
family
because australia has been so extremely
strict it's basically completely open
actually out the window right now
people just walking around on their
bikes some of them might be going to
clubs tonight i don't know what the kids
do these days
but essentially yes because it's been so
extremely strict over here um
and in new zealand they often have just
absolutely zero cases so i kind of just
wanted to walk through what this process
was like some of the really weird things
about it and the reality that i'm living
in now
not because i feel like i'm in any um
kind of unfortunate circumstance i'm
sure this is going to be really weird
for me mentally
as it has been for everyone who's done
it before me but really just to talk
about a unique circumstance that people
have a lot of questions about so
first things first for me to even get on
the plane um was a little bit difficult
the flights are
vehemently expensive or a lot more
expensive than they normally are for a
return trip and
in order to fly back uh
to america because that is where my job
is still obviously
i have to apply for an exemption um to
be able to fly
so we'll see how that goes getting on
the flight itself required
a negative covert test taken within
72 hours of the flight so you have to
take it the day before the day before
that or the day before that so that's
all i had to do was take a clover test
book the flight come to australia
landing in australia is where stuff gets
a little bit weird it felt more like a
pandemic
or like a zombie apocalypse than
anything i've seen
in the last year by a mile we get off
the plane
and it's all very sterile and and empty
there is absolutely nobody else until
at the end of a hallway me and the 15
other people who are on my flight maybe
20 not many we all get stopped by
someone at the end of a hallway who's
probably 20 meters away
wearing effectively a hazmat suit um
with a little clipboard
they tell us to stop and wait and then i
guess they look to their left
and wait until whichever group was
before us moves from whatever flight
they were on
and then allow us to move through
hallways all of which have signs
the likes of which i've never seen
before saying this is a through fair
absolutely no stopping so
they have to make sure that you are
packed in as a group
that you never see any other group that
you never get close to the people in the
hazmat suits
who have their clipboards etc and they
just
slowly move you through the airport in
sections
that was very weird seeing
so few people in an airport and the ones
that you do see
when you you know get home
are all in they're not like the hazmat
suits you're picturing but
you know just full like red or blue kind
of suits some of them had goggles they
all had masks of course we all had to
wear masks of course
just very strange unsettling strange
um so eventually we get to a corner
where people do come and speak to us and
they just ask us
how we feel essentially just do you feel
sick do you have any covered symptoms
they ask you a bunch of questions
you have to hand your travel card over
to airport officials um
this whole thing every single part of
this process again is like the group
moving being stopped moving being
stopped by one person who
is clearly trying very hard to stay
really far away from us so then you go
through the actual
order part which i don't think i'm
legally supposed to detail
just you know the person checking your
passport and asking you the questions i
don't think you're supposed to tell
people how
border patrol actually works get through
all of that again i'm an australian
citizen they're never gonna ask me a ton
of questions about coming home i'm
allowed to be here of course but then we
grab our bags
and usually where you'd go through
customs where if you have anything to
declare they
look through your bag or whatever that
was all australian military uh which
i've not seen before that is usually
customs officers but it was actually
uh all military this time around so you
know i get through there
and we're about to get outside of the
airport
uh there are cameras um so our group was
being filmed
again more run-ins with the military um
the police hand us this form to fill out
to give the hotel
and we are basically put on a bus and uh
have no knowledge of where we're going
to go so we get on the bus they make a
couple of stops i'm not sure why the
first guy had to stay at the hotel that
he did
um the australian military who i believe
were air force they were all super
friendly had to stay at a different
hotel and then i get dropped at my hotel
with the remaining passengers from the
flight and we have to wait for about 45
minutes on the bus
for the people in the bus in front of us
to get into the hotel
the way it works in australia is that
you have quarantine hotels so they are
um like if it wasn't clear i had no say
in this hotel
i did not know where i would be going
when i landed i didn't even know which
part of the city i would be in i didn't
know what the internet connection would
be like i didn't know what the room
would look like
and you do have to pay for it i don't
even know how much i have to pay
i just know that when i leave here i'm
gonna be charged
about two thousand dollars maybe two
thousand five hundred again i'll get
into the hotel part i'm just trying to
make this step by step
but to make that picture clear yeah i
had uh absolutely no idea where
the military or the police were taking
me as soon as i got out of the airport
um i don't think we were even really
encouraged to ask it was just sort of
you will get on this bus
you will not see anybody at any point
and you'll be dropped at a hotel where
you will remain for 14 days
so um an australian policeman walks on
the bus
gives us a little bit of a briefing and
then the hotel general manager i believe
came on and did the same kind of thing
there was stuff like
uh for any smokers there's no balcony
there's no windows of course you cannot
smoke inside the hotel
so uh you have to take nicotine patches
naturally i'm not a smoker but
that's what you have to do if you're a
smoker being locked in a hotel for 14
days
you are not allowed to leave the hotel
under any circumstances there's a very
significant fine for even walking in the
hallway and
you get meals delivered three times a
day because i'm working on u.s time i'm
still working for santa monica studio
um which was remote anyway and just
continues to be remote right now
i had to get my meal times adjusted for
american time which they were really
accommodating with they gave me a call
and
asked what times and told me i could
change it so i'm currently getting meals
delivered at
5am 11am and there is one more time
what's the other one
it's 5 8 and 11. it says on my bags
basically they deliver you these bags
and i guess the way that they track it
is that
hang on it says u.s time and then
they've got 11 am over here
so i'm sure there are other people in
the hotels who are having to work on
specific times but for me i'm waking up
at
um between three and five am and so they
deliver these meals three times a day
and basically they were saying what will
happen is you'll get a knock on the door
you wait 30 seconds it even says that on
the back of my door
you put your mask on you must be wearing
a mask and then you can take the food in
and i feel like that was the bulk of it
i asked about laundry because
14 days is a long time to spend without
being able to wash anything really
um we do have access to washing
detergent but otherwise there is a
washing service but it takes like three
days and costs 35
and you can only wash 10 items and i was
like it's fine i'll just wear the same
stuff
but uh otherwise it was yeah it was very
much just like
whatever you need let us know it is
weird people
seem to be fine the first few days and
then have more trouble beyond that
um and i'm still in the first few days
so let's see how i go
so then we get into the hotel uh the
form that the police officer
would have given people when we were at
the airport we have to fill out that is
just asking general information
like what flight we came from where
we're going after we get out of the
hotel what our
address is pretty basic information that
you have to fill out anytime you fly to
australia frankly
which is the slightly larger form uh i
handed that to
[Music]
the police so the police had a desk in
the hotel lobby
handed that form to a police officer
then we were taken to the concierge in
the hotel to ask if we have any food
allergies which i do not and then and
this part was very strange
um we weren't actually able to really
touch our bags at any point so
we got them from the airport and took
them to the bus but a member of the
australian military took my
bags from the bus and into the hotel
and then another member of the
australian military or the army
was the one who let me into the elevator
i wasn't even allowed into the elevator
and i said this to her i was like
it feels so weird being in a hotel and
not having a room key i feel like i'm
forgetting something and she said yeah
that's because i have your room key
so we don't even have our own room keys
um we are not allowed to leave
so she brings my bags in here
that's it that's the last person that i
saw
oh that's technically not true i did see
somebody today because they covet tested
me
so beyond that yeah i'm in this hotel
room i wasn't sure what the internet was
going to be like and that was a concern
for me because i wasn't sure if i'd be
able to do my job i mentioned that in
the video where i said i was coming back
to australia
it's totally fine it's not like it's
incredible but it's totally fine
the internet in this hotel might
actually be better than my internet at
my dad's place when i actually do get
out of here
it is obviously you know pretty regular
sized hotel room it is nice
but definitely do have asthma because i
have no fresh air
and there's a bath and i don't have a
bath at my apartment back home so i'm
okay
doing all right i also brought you know
my
oculus quest 2 to work out
i've got my xbox series s which i
brought because it is the smallest
console option just got my extended hard
drive down here
and i am recording this on a uh razer
laptop um which is very video game
capable
and i also brought a nintendo switch um
and a book so
a thing a lot of people ask about is the
food you can get food delivered to this
hotel through ubereats i know a lot of
australians said that they had a really
bad experience with this i've had stuff
delivered
my dad delivered me this beautiful
bouquet of flowers and some fruit
and my aunt delivered me a whole bunch
of tim tams and some sheeps which are
australian
snacks that i really love and always
really miss when i'm away but otherwise
this hotel
um gives you options for food so you get
this
pretty much every day um here's what
mine looks like
for reference so this is the thursday
menu which i would then put
under the door for the food that i'll
get on thursday for breakfast we have a
ham and cheese croissant a berry muffin
whole fruit and
fruit juice for lunch you can choose one
roast breast of turkey on turkish bread
with cranberry sauce and potato wedges
or leek and potato soup with crusty
bread dinner is grilled lamb kebabs with
couscous and mint yogurt or
moroccan spiced stuffed bell peppers
with couscous and mint yogurt
and a coconut cake and then they also
add in if you would like some alcohol
this little uh option to have shiraz so
you just like take the thing that you
want and put your room number
and then you slip this underneath the
door before 1 pm
and that's how they don't know what you
want the next day but yeah to give you
like kind of an idea of they sent me
more for breakfast than what's actually
there so i've got
this little muffin in here that i got
for breakfast today we have a whole
bunch of fruit
oh i'm out of focus uh which i've been
snacking on
we have avia thick and creamy yogurt
with mixed berries
basically a little mixed nuts type
situation here
papa juice orange juice and there's milk
and they give you your utensils as
little
plastic these are like wooden utensils
but yes the lunches and dinners have
been
um yesterday i had i think it was
probably pulled pork and coleslaw burger
that was delicious
um i've had some really well cooked fish
i think we had
cod with um beans and some potatoes like
it's been really good food
so that's been absolutely wonderful some
other things worth noting is that
i've gotten probably two phone calls
every day a nurse
legally has to call me every single day
just to ask how i'm doing
so they call every day they ask if your
mental health is okay and if you're
feeling okay and if you have any covered
symptoms but today
um i actually was covered tested which
meant that nurses knocked on my door
um i had to put my mask on and walk out
they made me stand
flat against the door like kind of like
this
while they're there so i was facing a
head they were facing towards me
they made me take my mask off they
swabbed the back of my throat and then
both of my nostrils which
you know i have had happen a few times
now and it really does
it makes me sneeze every time and then
i'm so self-conscious about the fact
that i'm sneezing while just having had
a gopher test
i don't imagine i have covered uh but
they basically said if it tests negative
they won't even tell me
um if it tests positive then i'll get a
phone call in a couple of days and
they'll tell me that i do
i don't know what actually happens if
you do have covid um but i am fully
vaccinated i got
the moderna um in april on the 14th and
they didn't ask me about that they asked
me for the details of it but the idea is
that even if you're vaccinated you still
can catch and spread covet it just
wouldn't be anywhere near as severe
so that's why even though i'm vaccinated
i do have to be in the hotel as
frustrating as it feels to be like i'm
gonna be fine
other people might not be and australia
is very coveted free so i think that's
all the main details
yeah i get these three bags every day um
you can get stuff delivered
like i said my family delivered me stuff
and i just got this package from amazon
so i can do that
you you then put your um bags outside
when you're done
with them if you want anything change
like towels or sheets you call and ask
and they'll leave them outside and then
you have to change them yourself of
course
they gave us uh you can see them just
here 26 i think
bottles of water for free you can
order alcohol but there are limits on it
so you can have six beers a day
and one uh bottle of wine but i believe
that's just
uh they're like responsible liquor laws
effectively
i do have a fridge no mini bar
everything's been removed but i do have
a fridge so i can keep stuff in there if
i need to
but i have not really been ordering
anything because the food is really good
um but like i said i'm sure when it
starts to feel more repetitive because
i'm sure they only have a certain amount
of meals that they
make don't imagine it's 14 unique meals
that i'll probably start to get pretty
bored
so we'll see how that goes mentally i
really am fine
the one weird thing that's happening to
me
is that what i can see outside of this
window
my brain doesn't believe is real and i'm
already at that point
the things that i'm seeing outside of
this window
because it's a big window my brain is
convinced is a simulation or a screen
it's really weird but that is it for me
today everyone just kind of an update um
like i said let me know if you have any
questions and i'll probably post another
video about
how this is going or any updates that i
have next week so i guess i'll see you
then
bye